well I think China already is pulling us
out of the economic crisis the
large-scale purchasing of global
commodity and said China has gone into
effect over the last several months i
think is one of the main drivers of
keeping the global economy alive and
sustainable i think also that china is
actually sort of show great leadership
around the green movement energy
efficiency in areas like that and i
think that that's going to be one of the
big drivers of the global economy going
forward one of the big job creators and
I think China is getting it much quicker
than many of us in the united states are
getting it thanks